oh-oh-oh let's watch you know the rules
lights freakin do these my brother came
strapped for Thanksgiving that's true
[Laughter]
you can agree human exists right we're
here I'm here I exist right I like that
way of pointing out an argument ever
expanding your universe you can agree
you exist right I don't think that too
correlates all right all right you lost
me on the rush my guy look he thought he
was gonna that's funny I seen this when
she start licking my Gooch from the back
a classic are you life you lose classic
it's called find the invisible cow it's
hot and cold but it says the word cow
Loki wanna try it though I just find the
most amazing and I have to tell you oh
where is he well that was mildly amusing
you should put that on the subreddit a
good time thinking of a good analogy it
was just an assignment if the rare
insult
[Laughter]
little roasted vegetables never hurt
anybody so perfectly cut without the
audio even getting in anyone down to
trade my yellow nd hood for a black or a
white one it has no dings or anything
perfect condition whose a Wallace trade
as soon as possible
John payin how did that happen oh my god
wholesome meme how did that have so good
views No
rats uh-huh what if they learn about it
in rat school and you just made that a
little homey even more sad where the
hell would have a rat as a pet they're
literally plagues who the hell would
have a rat as a plague man you're just
vibing and then one day your girlfriend
is sucking BP through the air and then
you take the V R and you punch the BP
with your fist is that gay why people be
like meanwhile I get robbed shake my
head and crime peepee [ __ ] you my pant
and come beautiful timing well done
can't wait for Alex what is it half
light 1.5 they're like oh we can't we
can't call it half life 3 which just
can't get let the Nerds have it Wow
another wholesome Mima
here you go little fishies yes there's
plenty for all of us he getting water
not giving food to the free this says a
lot about our society I gotta say mean
school I'm glad this exists thank God
for this David Bowers says meme school
means school that's hilarious
I made a ha ha Meem he said meme shrek
shrek is meme ha ha ha ha ha what are
those sounds he screams like toad for
mario bros you're right he it is
help me it was up slapping me oh god
he's fed up Megan stop
- I told me that puffer fish is only
puff up if they are really stressed and
they can actually die from stress if
they puff up so we should stop laughing
at puffy puffs fish's getting slapped
because I feel bad about them now can't
find the funny I agree
this one trash substitute teacher the
Bell doesn't dismiss do the studio ha
anime that was beautiful
it can't be true please someone tell me
it isn't true
oh yeah I've seen this ninja walks like
virgin this is so sad Nina can't be
virgin they gave me budget Wow sorry I
don't walk how society sees his shed
it's how I effing walk stop calling me a
virgin he did not tweet that roblox that
boy has a gift that boy is a talent that
good boy will go far in life that's a
chance
alright ninja that's a chance
[Music]
Hey good time good time impressive
impressive Bernice on a new record buddy
please share if you think they should
flip Oklahoma upside down and let Texas
wear it as a hat smash like on this
video and subscribe if you agree and
I'll make sure it happens
vote Felix 20 something but you can't
mine obsidian with iron axe oh God dolma
make him stop
oh he's wasting so much time I can't
look at this
No
all right my final mess you ruin it your
lazy eye is not that noticeable no look
at this dude he probably got that
because he stuck as a child remember
that there were parents told you that if
you do this it will get stuck why
parents lie about that isn't it kind of
mean to two kids that actually have a
lazy eye or something to say that it's
because they cross their eyes on purpose
and it gets stuck don't do it they will
get stuck I remember when I learned that
I'm like alright better if I'm gonna do
it I better make it count because then
you know I'm treading on dangerous
territory here okay this is epic oh wow
this was totally worth it they're virgin
walk Roger this meme has made me so
aware of my posture this meme has done
more for my posture than anything I've
ever ever anything ever could
some up in the Allen Walker
are you okay yeah
hey smash like on that one very nice
good meme this dude really acting like
making a trickshot was a life-altering
experience my story of falling Wow
no attempting my most difficult shot I
was getting so close I'm going to make
the shot I just know it but then I had
poo pee my pants
the pain was immense eventually I jumped
it was hard I felt hopeless I can't quit
not yet did he get sign face sign him
right as soon as you saw him make that
shot I mean it's a good shot I'm not
gonna lie and be like bruh
but the only reason those shots are cool
is if you only see he the result that's
why like don't try and make the fail
looking cool oh my god skate three I
wanna play this so badly it's so
annoying to plug in my playstation 3 and
you need a special oh my god Keanu
Reeves Keanu Chris D'Elia
good means today oh you made a stinky
dummy idiot idea wow this is why you
shouldn't have kids just send them off
to an island I've said it many times
send the kids away to Islands it's not
my fault you decide to have bad bear
it's not my fault me showing my mum a
funny me
it's funny because it's accurate and
relatable and why there you know when
they start a meme like that the reaction
is never gonna be good
wait what it's not a spider
it's like those that coin eaters isn't
it but oh no thought it was gonna get
fed up and attack his head yeah Loki was
waiting for the thing to come out and
eat his [ __ ] face or something she
cheated on me what damn anyway thought
can never trust even anime girls these
days chick in my head downtown walking
fast oh very good very good
oh my come on join the barbecue cops let
the man grill on top of the car stop
trying to ruin everything
oh my god that's so cute oh it's gonna
be hard resisting the temptation of
getting a she been there when we live in
Japan what what the hell they're talking
dey could never replace Edgar of course
me after I finally catch a baby ah yes
I can't wait to eat baby other
I can't wait to devour that little
fifty-year-old meat no no no no no 0-4
come on bro no is that come on brain
wake up you got this I like I somewhere
applied it's minus 4 cringe cringe I
could tell that it was minus 4 as soon
as I saw it that's one of the classic
clips a classic you laugh you loose I've
seen it too many times I have no left or
left inside of me not these
I've already you've already done this
joke I've seen it already
stop it you can't use up oh my god kind
of dumbbell alright okay what okay fine
hey I use the table to win the table
tennis very epic see something you don't
have his booty of a bathroom as me so
you come in a little go down but showers
on Dan stop flexing bra Jesus's these
are the same kind of people that bicep
B&W or something it's too good
that is dead she's gone oh god damn I
wish I was real
that's so funny they're always so if you
mention the other AI they're like oh
they are also super good AI just admit
that you hate each other great me oh
that's great I left I laughs I made the
Lavi haha alright guys that's all the
time we have for you to get there oh if
you enjoyed smash like check out the
merch subscribe
epic bye bye Adel Hey
[Music]
you are entering a new era where you
shall grasp
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marnya ender and buttons need you
[Music]
the timer you will face but crawlers
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne Bertie is the game to play I'm
not supposed to have my opinion about
that but the prizes
you